we've all been in the situation where
economically everything's going crazy
and you're in it you're right in the
middle of the tornado getting caught up
in all the economic political stuff how
good does it feel to Fly Above That to
finally get that out of your life to
where you're not part of it guys this
stuff goes in Cycles okay this is not
the last we're ever going to hear about
forgiveness this is not the last time
we're ever going to have a weird economy
okay next time make it like put it in
stone next time you're flying above this
by the time this circles back around
again your life financially is going to
be in order and you are going to just
sit back and watch everybody else be
weird and get you know be worried about
this stuff and your your loans are going
to be gone make that your choice today